first of all it's like movie star stuff
again once again we're back movies are
back being on red carpets everybody how
does that feel it feels really good
especially with this one this is like an
Ode to old Hollywood to the to where it
all started
um you know the the Glam but also the
debauchery and the chaos and everything
else that goes with it okay you play an
aging movie star in this and um right
well it's aging you're playing it yeah
an elder Statesman okay in in real life
though you still feel young but when do
you think you passed the Baton to these
young guys oh I'm already I've already
passing baton you see so much great work
coming up and and I've always said it's
a younger person Sport and I think that
you know you're seeing new modes of
Storytelling that really excites me and
it just comes it always comes from the
younger generation it's got to come
it's the Natural Evolution after doing
all the all the fighting and action
stuff was it good just to get back to
the Glam and the acting
well I mean you know there's some good
drama in this one but it's also um it's
really funny and uh it's it's big and
it's um I don't know it's it it makes me
really be proud to be part of this
lineage of of you know getting to
contribute to storytelling and my little
form and and all the people that have
come before us and all that will come
after so okay there are also some crazy
scenes there's the opening party you're
like whoa whoa whoa what party scene is
almost 30 minutes I think what was it
like when they yelled cut because there
there's a lot of naked folks there's
there's all kinds of stuff going on
there's a there's a lot of naked folks
yes there are
um it was uh it took about two weeks so
you know day one it was like wow we're
really going for it here aren't we and
then like day three you're like okay
we're really going for it and then like
two weeks into it you're just like
just another day just another day at
work and Margo snuck in a kiss you
weren't supposed she wasn't supposed to
kiss you and she kissed you no there's
always room for like uh
um I guess character interpretation and
and believe me that's the tamest thing
she does in this in this that's what she
is on fire on this she is it's the it's
the best I've ever seen her and we can't
say enough about Damon chazelle because
he is in my book four for four he's a
Phenom he's one of the
great writer directors of our time and
and for me it was a real privilege
[Music]